oui nous avons une question de
libération sur qui peut décider
d'éventuelles poursuites propres par
jour ça ça revient un peu à votre
question
de tout à l'heure s'agissant de Marlène
Schiappa et celle de pnfel ou d'autres
acteurs alors je voudrais là-dessus dire
d'abord qu'on ne peut pas poser la
question
du mensonge du parjure etc pour la seule
Marlène Schiappa bon soit on la pose
globalement soit on la pose pas soit à
dire que comment dire la ministre serait
comment dire la cible d'une mission
d'enquête ce n'est pas le cas
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas le cas donc
c'est une question qui se pose de
manière générale pour l'ensemble des
personnes auditionnées deuxième point
c'est que c'est quelque chose de très
précis en réalité on ne peut pas faire
la confusion entre des paroles publiques
qui ont été faites sur un plateau de
télévision ou à la presse dans lesquels
il est clair que les mensonges ne fût-ce
que lorsqu'on dit effectivement qu'on a
qu'on ne sait qu'on n'a pas participé en
rien à la sélection bon voilà donc de
leçons où on dit ça et au vu des
commissions d'enquête il y a pas il y a
pas de doute
cette phrase était pour le moins
malheureuse voilà et il aurait mieux
valu sans doute pour la ministre partir
sur écouter j'assume ma responsabilité
nous allons regarder dans le détail ce
qui s'est passé et on verra bien je
pense que c'était plus positif que de
dire
je ne suis concerné en rien par cette
affaire je pense que ça aurait été une
meilleure une meilleure attitude mais ça
c'est pas du parleur c'est tout
simplement une parole publique et c'est
au
aux hommes et aux femmes qui entendent
les éléments de se faire sa propre
opinion sur sur le sujet mais on n'est
pas sur une une mesure qui concerne en
tout cas le Sénat on verra si le PNF se
saisit de quelques questions que ce soit
mais a priori c'est plutôt une question
qui relève du débat public
plutôt que d'autres choses
et donc un autre un autre point qui
n'est pas important c'est que il faut
établir en réalité le faux témoignage et
ça c'est très on est dans un aspect
juridique donc le faux témoignage il
faut l'établir alors lorsque vous avez
par exemple
deux témoignages uniquement l'homme qui
dit une chose et un votre témoignage qui
dit autre chose bah c'est pas de nature
à faire marquer un parjure parce que
lequel des deux est concerné finalement
bon donc c'est pour établir les choses
de manière juridique il faut en réalité
avoir un faisceau d'indice beaucoup plus
large avec des positions beaucoup plus
nombreuses qui permettent à ce moment-là
de dire de dire les choses de cette
façon là
d'autre part ce qu'il faut bien relever
c'est que quel type peut être les
tentatives souvent maladroites de
dissimulation des uns et des autres
quelques pu être les techniques de
contournement des questions posées ça a
été évoqué tout à l'heure pour autant la
mission au final a pu établir très
clairement les responsabilités et n'a
pas été gêné dans sa capacité à établir
les responsabilités des uns et des
autres
peut-être je vais vous donner la parole
mais peut-être puisque j'avais fait
partie j'étais président de la
commission d'enquête pour illustrer les
propos de
Claude rénale sur le coup économique et
financier de la pollution de l'air où il
y avait eu par jour
comment a été établi par jour lors des
auditions d'un certain nombre de
personnes ou de personnalité
donc on faisait évidemment
comment dirais-je
ont demandé le témoignage sous serment
et on demandait si aux personnes si
elles avaient des liens économiques et
financiers particulier et une personne
qui avait témoigné avait dit que n'en
avait avec personne et c'est là encore
un peu plus d'un an après
la publication de nos rapports
un journaliste de mémoire de libération
qui m'appelle en me disant voilà on a
une information est-ce que vous êtes au
courant
donc je réponds bien sûr que non mais en
disant je m'en inquiète tout de suite et
c'était un vendredi soir dès le lundi on
était au travail le mardi on informait
la personne auditionnée qui est venue le
jeudi et qui a reconnu à ce moment-là
avoir un lien avoir des contreparties il
y avait quand même une conséquence pas
négligeable puisque c'est une personne
qui travaillait pour un groupe pétrolier
et par sa profession médicale qui disait
qu'il n'y avait aucun lien entre
la pollution liée
au carburant et aux émissions et des
problèmes de santé publique enfin donc
ça a été assez simple mais là dans ce
cas là c'est premièrement il fallait
d'abord que la personne témoigne
deuxièmement on a transmis
la position du président au bureau et
c'est le bureau qui après à décider de
transmettre ou non à la justice et au
final la personne était condamnée
[Musique]